[Music]
treaty's containing in very succinct and
abbreviated form some contrasts and
differences in the customs of the people
of Europe and this province of Japan
many of their customs are so distant
foreign and far removed from our own
that it is difficult to believe the one
can find such stark contrasts in customs
among us and people who are so civilized
have such lively genius and are as
naturally intelligent as these Japanese
concerning men their persons and their
clothing Europeans are for the most part
tall and well-built the Japanese for the
most part are not as tall or robust as
we are Europeans consider large eyes
beautiful the Japanese think they are
horrendous and consider beautiful eyes
those that are narrow in the inner
corner of the eye we don't think it's
strange to have white eyes the Japanese
consider it monstrous and it is rare
among them Europeans have long and
occasionally aquiline noses
the Japanese have short noses and small
nostrils Europeans generally have full
beards the Japanese usually have sparse
scraggly beards what Europeans take
pride and honour in their births the
Japanese take pride in a little tuft of
hair that is bound at the the back of
their heads among us men always keep
their hair groomed and consider it a
front to have it removed the Japanese
remove their hair with tweezers enduring
pain and tears in the process among us
there are many men and women who have
freckles the Japanese well fair skinned
rarely have freckles among us it is rare
for a man or woman to be pockmarked
among the Japanese it is very common and
many lose their sight from the polls
among our cities considered unclean and
uncivilized to have long fingernails
Japanese men as well as noble women wear
some of their nails like talons among us
facial scars are considered a deformity
the Japanese are proud of their scars
and because the wounds are poorly
treated these scars look were even more
deformed we dressed the same throughout
the four seasons of the year the
Japanese changed their dress three times
a year
natsu katabira aqui i wass a Fuyu kimono
among us to wear clothing made from
printed fabrics would be considered
foolishness and nonsense among the
japanese everyone except that bonds
isn't old men with shaven pates wear
clothing made from printed fabrics among
nasa a new looking clothing is created
nearly every year in Japan styles are
always the same without ever changing
[Music]
we use a double-edged sword the Japanese
user a Cutlass that only has a single
cutting edge our swords are tested on
lumber or animals
the Japanese insist upon using their
swords on human corpses we regard
strolling as great recreation as well as
very healthful and calming the Japanese
do not go strolling at all and they are
amazed and view our strolling as a
hardship and dependence women their
persons and their customs in Europe
young woman's supreme honour and
treasure is her chastity and the in
violet cloister of her purity women in
Japan pay no mind to virginal purity nor
does a loss of virginity deprive them of
honour or matrimony women in Europe
greatly prize and do everything possible
to have blond hair women in Japan abhor
it and - although can't make the hair
black women in Europe part their hair at
the forehead in Japan they shave their
foreheads and conceal the part women in
Europe rarely add hair from other
sources to their own women in Japan by
many wigs bought through trade with
China women in Europe think it is
unattractive for their face powder and
makeup to be noticeable women in Japan
think the more layers of white powder
applied the more genteel women in Europe
make use of methods and concoctions to
whiten their teeth Japanese women use
iron and vinegar to make their mouths
and teeth black
[Music]
in Europe men walk in front and women
behind in Japan the men walk behind in
the women in front in Europe property is
held in common by husband and wife in
Japan each owns his or her own and
sometimes the woman lends hers to the
husband at exorbitant rates of interest
women in Europe never leave the house
without their husbands permission in
Japan the women are free to go where
they're pleased without their husbands
knowledge in Europe while they do exist
abortions are infrequent in Japan this
is so common that there are women who
have had 20 abortions in Europe an
infant is Israeli almost never killed
after birth in Japan the women step on
the neck and kill any children to whom
they give birth that they believe they
cannot feed in Europe women ordinarily
prepare meals in Japan men do the
cooking and noblemen consider it
something excellent to go into the
kitchen to prepare food in Europe it is
considered offensive for women to drink
wine in Japan it is very common and on
festive occasions the women sometimes
get drunk concerning children and their
customs boys in Europe wear their hair
short in Japan they all let it grow
freely up to the age of 15 in Europe
children sleep in cradles and they use
little carts to teach them to walk in
Japan they have none of these things and
use only the AIDS that nature provides
with us it is normal to whip and punish
a child in Japan this is very rare and
they only reprimand them
our children learn first to read and
then to write in Japan they commence
with writing and then learn to read
children in Europe are reared with many
kindnesses tendinous and good food and
clothing in Japan they grow up
half-naked and essentially lack all
kindness and pleasures European parents
handle affairs directly with their
children in Japan
everything is carried out using messages
and a third party in Europe children
inherit upon the death of their parents
in Japan parents relinquish their estate
early in life in order to hand over the
inheritance of their children various
and extraordinary things that do not fit
neatly in the preceding chapters
we show great emotion when we lose our
fortunes and our houses burned down the
Japanese as far as outward appearances
go take all of this very lightly among
us it is a great offense to call someone
a liar to their face the Japanese laugh
at this and considerate polite behavior
among us no one kills another except
those who have jurisdiction and
authority to do so in Japan anyone can
kill in his own house we are terrified
to kill a man but think nothing of
killing cows chickens and dogs the
Japanese are terrified to see animals
killed but killing men is commonplace
among us no one is killed for stealing
unless they steal above a certain sum in
Japan they are killed no matter how
trifling the some among us if we kill
another with just cause or in
self-defense we are spared in Japan he
who kills another must die and if he
does not appear another is killed in his
place among us
people are not crucified however this is
very common in Japan among us servants
of reprimanded and serfs are punished by
whipping in Japan the reprimand and
punishment is bedding among us men women
and children are afraid of the night in
Japan to the contrary neither young nor
old have any fear of it we generally
speaking our afraid of snakes and are
disgusted by touching them
the Japanese easily and fearlessly pick
them up and some eat them we play ball
using our hands the Japanese play with
their feet when we hit the ball we hit
it up high against the wall in Japan
when they hit the ball they keep it
closer to the ground and always strike
it from
on the side we embrace when we take our
leave or come back from somewhere the
Japanese do not embrace at all and they
laugh when they see it done in Europe
people socialize and recreate with
others in plazas and in streets in Japan
they do so only in their houses and use
the streets solely for walking among us
a fake smile is considered frivolous in
Japan it is thought to be dignified and
a sign of elevated status in Europe
clarity is sought in words and ambiguity
is avoided in Japan ambiguous words are
considered the best language and are the
most highly esteemed we are very free
with our anger and have little control
over our impatience
they are singularly in control of
themselves and are very restrained and
discreet
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]